hi just wandering the halls of CNN
looking for Anderson Cooper a Neil and I
are here for our first television
interview
okay thank you you we are headed over to
our day-to-day office which we have
occupied prior to the Oscars you could
let me know maybe next week or that
would be places this was our preliminary
board we put up with all the categories
and the different act breaks and stuff
like that so it's completely different
now I'd adobe today we're doing a lot of
stuff we're going over seating we're to
put nominees and how to get them to the
stage quicker and stuff like that we
usually keep Ted and Neal's truck but
today we didn't bring up it's a little
chilly we're going to show this to you
get Craig Zach okay we're gonna shoot
them actually coming out of the box guys
trophy presenters have always been these
like bombshell babes so we start the
contest this year college students can
submit themselves with a personal like
video message as to why they are
committed to film and from these
submissions we will pick at least six
trophy presenters so therefore everybody
on that stage has a reason for being
there in a love of film rabbit and you
talk bang okay every aspect of the show
is being examined and defined in a
different light than it has been in
previous years part of the whole thing
is about we are switching on ball but
the red carpet row it's not gonna be a
traditional red carpet show you get a
little bit of a look yeah doing some
different things oh wow oh they are
really dramatic Oscar red carpet
experience or because it's going to be a
little bit different we didn't go for
the big things only we went for the big
things first and then we went for every
microscopic little thing after that we
believe that it will all add apples up
because I think the best way to write
jokes is not to try too hard but you see
what actually bubbles are here your
unconscious well you have to do two
different things you got to be funny
right and cutting-edge but you're also
got to make the serious stuff sound not
boring
okay let's do this let's do it lots of
changes this year lots of experiments
lots of things that will work lots of
things that may not work but we won't
know till that night but we're not
recreating previous shows we're going to
take the risk of trying new things it's
what I should have talked about on CNN